hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to owe
McCauley why do you keep popping up here
I'm sure you're a nice guy hell you were
probably a nice kid but man did you pick
some dumb dumb dumb movies dan we're
here to look at another stinker with
Richie Rich who can seem like the
perfect kid at the time to show us a
subject matter I'm sure would have gone
over really well today how the 1% live
brought to you by the ingenious
visionary director of How to Lose a Guy
in 10 days Richie Rich brings to the big
screen a story nobody demanded to see
from an actor clearly going through
puberty based on the comic strip that
younger kids have never heard of with
those credentials how could you not
green like this well time is money so
let's start spending this is Richie Rich
so back in the 90s when we still had an
economy a young boy is born to a
millionaire named Richard rich the boy's
name Richie Rich you know you ever
wonder if either the father or son would
have a different life if their parents
named them poor I broke hey that's my
legally born name which even go through
the typical rich kid jokes like playing
catch while doing business meetings
genetically altering a dog's body to
have money signs on it creepy even
building a giant mounted portrait to
themselves oh people of today's current
financial status but just love this bill
but his life isn't all just fun and
games there's also the importance of
keeping up the illusion that his life is
not all fun and games like having and do
a ribbon-cutting at a tool Factory
fitting as many would consider this
character to be all United to on behalf
of my dad
thanks for the wrenches I know my dad
loves socket wrenches I know I love
socket wrenches and my mom knew what a
sucker wrench was I'm sure she loved it
too so as you may have noticed by this
point in his life cocaine is sounding
less like the kid from home
and more like the sped up audio of
Sylvester Stallone I'd like to stay but
I gotta go do my homework it's been real
yo Adrian come on let's go I skate he
also has a little butler named Cadbury
and no he doesn't talk like this where
but he does manage to keep a close eye
on little Richie serie is not secured
sir and don't touch him it's my job to
protect him
very well mr. Ferguson to grab him like
that again and you will need protection
we British are known for our strength
and athletic abilities hey poor kid
what are you talking about he's the
richest kid in the world you don't have
children do you Dave my wife can't
conceive thanks for that salt in the
wound
it was then that Richie realized there
was something missing in his life
something simple something money could
not buy
movie we'll get to man stuff later but
for now his dad is back from a business
trip only to find that he has to leave
again excuse me sir
it's a telephone call the president what
country this one sir uh probably needs
another loan yeah that joke doesn't date
this movie at all actually it kind of
makes it timeless but don't worry we had
that guy who was supposed to be huge
from whose lines of anyway but then
messed up by choosing movies like well
you're a branch ten times stickier than
the strongest adhesive known to man
I call it cement yeah his job is to sort
of be the cue of the movie making all
sorts of gadgets and weapons that I'm
sure will not make an appearance in the
film's climax a hundred bees working
overtime couldn't pollinate like this
baby behold
Robo Pete yes you never know when the
world might need a robo B in their lives
the possibilities are just so limiting
actually doesn't it sort of look like
the bee from Simon Says in fact don't
think inventors of those things look
suspiciously similar to my god could it
be they're some sort of conspiring
connection between Simon Says and Richie
Rich yeah who gives a shit we then meet
the villain of our movie how do we know
he's the villain because he's played by
John Larroquette
and let's face it if jim lehrer can't
ever play the good guy in something your
movie would just die faster your
donations are costing the corporation
over a billion dollars a year and I
think it's just time we asked ourselves
what are we getting for it he's their
advisor and doesn't like how charitable
their donations are and how wasteful
their inventions may seem we have
glasses to help us see better and
hearing aids to help us hear better why
shouldn't we have something to help us
smell better this thing's way out of
whack can I be excused thank you hey yo
I'm like a mini Tony Danza yeah
if I may might I suggest that you
consider beefing up the security system
oh I don't think that'll be necessary
Lawrence I mean after all all of our
real valuables are locked in the rich
family vault vault so he makes the
incredible discovery that the rich
family is rich and that taking control
of their vault might make him even
richer
so to be fair it looks like he's pretty
ritual
ready he just fired a limo driver for
parking too close to a puddle of water
how much more money do you need all I
just want enough to buy a spaceship go
to the edge of the universe travel
through the outer rim have an
existential journey itself and become
the next evolution of mankind therefore
being in control of all the universe but
I bet you call me selfish for wanting
that dead link gone
okay dead hiya slugger okay don't you
just love early CG technology that's
trying to look hip but instead just
gives you diarrhea of fear
okay dead hiya slugger
and why do his pupils get bigger it's
like he's looking to suck out my soul
hyah
so Richie does what most kids would do
around that age gives his dad a call
when he has a zit did you do that
growing up I'm getting a shit what do
you think could we talk about this later
oh sure dad I'm sorry I'll shoot Annette
bye
see ya see this is one of the problems
with the movie the Richie character is
so bland that we don't really know what
to make of a scene like this is it funny
because he's talking to him at such a
delicate time or because he's bringing
it up to him at all most kids don't act
this way but we have no idea if that's
the way the character is or if the
writer just doesn't know much about kids
nothing else about Richie himself is
noticeably that strange so we don't know
who's the one who's supposed to be
acting out of line here the father or
the son it's like the Animaniacs joke
knock knock who's there
max max who lets wants to come in and go
crazy
okay now that's not really a joke is it
you see because it makes no sense it
does if you know max but I don't know
max if you did you'd be laughing same
thing here we see how Richie lives but
really we know nothing about him just
that he has a lot of stuff so a lot of
these jokes fall flat some of the rich
jokes are funny but if you can't gauge
the reaction of the character this stuff
is being bounced off of you yourself
don't know how you're supposed to react
all we ever get is that he wants to get
out more so he manages to bring in well
let's call him what they really are a
bunch of tokens the token black kid the
token fat kid the token cool kid and the
token girl kid we know who you are
what no chopper and God said unto Noah
bring me one of every stereotype and you
will have your crappy 90s movie and Noah
said no and God struck him down with
light so Ritchie tries to befriend them
but in a very strange strategy they
decide it's best not to befriend the
incredibly rich child yeah I mean what
could they possibly gain hanging out
with the richest kid in the world so
stupid what are you doing here
well I was wondering maybe I can play
with you guys play not know who they got
me with the not card even though
technically they never said anything
positive to have in that card following
duo it still hurts
I wish there is something I could do to
combat it or fight back but like God is
just too cool it's the perfect defense
it will never not be popular as long as
I live
The Walking SunnyD commercial finally
agrees to meet up with him and Neela's
to say they're impressed
ain't no household hood I'm the black
one luncheon is served all right
food I like this place I'm the fat one
food is my only identity lost Richie was
of the opinion that his young guests
deserve a break today
I believe that's bad screenwriting for
insert your plonk here no goddamn
until important Baba's this gotta put
him fat oh my goodness a grenade dose so
they ride ATVs speedboats the iron wolf
from Six Flags Great America that
they're not claiming is in their
backyard it's a whole lot of fun but he
then comes across some bad news
apparently Larroquette put a bomb on his
parents plane and they crashed into the
ocean they managed to stay afloat but
sailing nobody can find him with them
out of the way Larroquette thinks he can
run the businesses and shut down the
factories that he finds pointless but
what this lets Shalu taking over the
industry well not since hero pig have I
seen business ethics so inspired
please I'm seated okay
I'm not gonna lie that was pretty badass
how much stock do I own 51% of the
voting stock yes but you're not of legal
age to exercise your voting right I
stand in loco parentis and guardian ad
litem to master Richard and accordingly
I give him full proxy power and
authority like a motherfucking boss
so Ritchie is now running things and
like always he does a good job of it you
know wouldn't it be more awesome in one
of these movies if the hero just crash
and burns the company Billy Beane is
tried to reinvent a system that's been
working for years hey Donny do you think
you lose your job you're discounting
what scouts have done for a hundred and
fifty years
my tone just not working out
some employee downsizing now I'm sorry
you mean fired people it was our job to
cut the fat my father never fired
anybody he always said that when people
are secure in their jobs they work
harder they work happier they work
better that's the dumbest thing I ever
heard nobody has a perfect hiring record
you're going to make mistakes and hire
the wrong people like people who are
under qualified or overqualified or put
a fucking bomb on a plane and ball your
parents up don't you think that's our
firing offense you mental laxative of a
movie all those in favor of my motion
all opposed
I drink your milkshake yeah maybe for
NAMBLA weekly I hate that kid so he
thinks of another way to take him down
he has the Butler Cadbury arrested for
I don't know making his eggs smaller or
something we received an anonymous tip
and searched a rich mansion bomb parts
detonation devices found in Herbert
Cadbury's roof you're under arrest for
the murder of Richard and Regina rich
Sookie's framed for blowing up the folks
but Ritchie tries to break him out with
one of the scientists inventions I want
you to give this to my uncle he suits
what's this very special toothpaste just
really sensitive teeth well this is
Chicago and it is Kirk County
so I'll allow it are you got 10 minutes
to do whatever oh so he gets him this
stuff just in time to have a thrilling
off-screen battle
that's saved us a lot of money so he
breaks out and they put together that
larroquette is behind everything but
Larroquette also finds out that the
vault he wants to get into is
voice-activated by the parents and guess
who they just found oh my god their life
it'sa me Mario Batali so he calls him
the Burger King kids club and in an
ironic twist Col Kent is actually trying
to break into the house this time oh I
do hope his head gets burnt by a
flamethrower Ritchie you wouldn't
believe what they did to me it was a
human they see that the scientist has
been kidnapped
wait we was guarding him and he sees if
he can whip up a diversion to distract
the guards what does he use box fortune
balls and by the way what the hell is up
with the adult mothers staying behind
while the young little kids go in to
save the day
maybe she sees them with the canary you
send in before entering a coal mine
this calls for a fat guy moment you guys
go on ahead
oh just a second okay what is that tux
what what is that tux
my invention smartest buttons mighty
pinches
- bad tux Mars infections - bad times
Marty Steakhouse - that does chew but it
turns out larroquette found the parents
and forces them to open the vault with
their voice-activated combination
singing our song Syfy code accepted
Thank You Vives and Butthead hey I don't
get that meanwhile the rest of the kids
fight off the bad guys with those who
like Ian vengeance or how do you say it
again why is bad time yeah those as we
discover that the vault is not filled
with riches but more precious memories
and to the film's credit they do turn
out to funny lines in a row here or the
gold bars
yeah the diamonds II negotiable bearer
bonds the money where's the bloody in
banks where else and the stock market
shoot them shoot them now please what's
the matter mister banjo can't do it
yourself on this occasion I think I'll
make an exception
cool a head for the head so let's keep
out of the vault and have a thrilling
climax I'm no dish more all right
you go now there's your PG rating folks
aren't you glad all you parents in the
audience and be dragged to this flick
just for that hey Cole can testify for
Jackson I'm sure he takes great offense
at that
hence ladies still in this movie oh who
cares they knock out the bad guy he
serves his community service and bland D
bland finds out that his friends are the
real riches now our son really is the
richest boy in the world he has friends
so I guess that means he doesn't need
the money and he'll be handing it over
to some sort of charity or we'll just
roll the credits hey if it ends the
movie faster I guess this isn't like the
worst Culkin film or anything it's got a
few memorable moments and one or two
funny lines but the main character is so
bland and the story itself is so phoned
in that it's pretty hard to get invested
I will admit I did sort of like the
butler character as he seemed much more
protective and caring than Ritchie's
parents but yeah how about Ritchie's
parents did they ever learn anything did
they ever discover how to raise a kid
better was there ever a story art do
they find out anything about their money
or their son I don't think this movie
cared enough to answer that question
hell I don't even think it cared enough
to ask it it's just a last-ditch effort
to cash in on a kid celebrity status
before his testicles drop if you want to
get rich in life start saving your money
by not buying this piece of crap I'm a
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to or play the stock market
that usually helps do
voice patterns